this is where you steal the show nobody
nobody knows your name make them
remember your name and don't miss a dunk
all right good luck brother Jamal
who you got in the dunk contest
oh what do you got what do you got I got
Mac McClung
yes
they got some hops
can't this kid right here got some help
what
no way no way
excuse me
[Applause]
what did I tell you
what'd I tell you he hungry
be hungry
I told you yeah
unless it he ain't in the league and I'm
he hungry
God damn
[Applause]
excuse me sexy man
whoa what was that I completely missed
it yeah what was that
yo what was that what do you do
a dude that ain't even an NBA ain't
gonna win that thing
[Music]
Michael Michael I got that
government
I think so
Gate City I don't know what that means
foreign
[Applause]
thank you